[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: Last
time, so we're talking
about a set of real numbers.
And last time, I stated
the following theorem
about the existence
and properties of R
that make it special.
So the theorem is, there
exists a unique ordered field
with the least upper
bound property containing
the rational numbers.
So remember, a
field was a set that
had operations plus
and multiplication.
An ordered field also this
set has an order on it.
And this order interacts
with the operations
of addition and multiplication
in natural ways.
And the least upper
bound property
means every non-empty subset
which is bounded above
has a supremum in the set.
So least upper bound
property, meaning the supremum
belongs in R, not necessarily
in the non-empty set,
which is bounded above.
And we saw last time that
q, the rational numbers,
does not have this property.
By looking at that set,
q positive rational q
squared less than 2.
That set was bounded
above but didn't
have a supremum in
rational numbers,
because the square
root of 2 essentially
is not a rational number.
And the square root of
2 would be the supremum.
So just based on this
theorem which characterizes
and constructs R, the
set of real numbers,
we're now going to prove
facts about real numbers
and soon turn to limits.
So as I said in the
beginning, limits
is or are the central
object of study in analysis.
That's what analysis
is, the study of limits.
The real analysis
part, or the real,
and that is that
we're doing this
within the setting
of the real numbers.
So now, let me just point
out something kind of simple
about the real numbers.
So I mean, extremely simple
fact about the real numbers
is it's not discrete
like the integers are.
So for the integers, if I
take one integer and another,
it's not necessarily
the case that there's
an integer strictly
in between them.
There's not an integer
between 0 and 1.
And but R does
satisfy this property,
essentially because
it's a field.
So and it's an ordered field.
So what's the simple fact,
if x, y are real numbers,
and x is less than y, then
there exists a real number
r, a little r, so that x is
less than r is less than y.
And I can give you r explicitly.
r is equal to x plus y over 2.
All right, that's
not so surprising.
Now, this statement
here is also true
if I replace r with
rational numbers.
Namely if I had two rational
numbers, 1 less than the other,
then there exists a rational
number in between that's
between x and y.
I just again, define
r in this way.
Now, a natural question
is the following,
is that if x and y are in
R, and x is less than y,
then does there--
I'll put a question mark
over that-- does there
exist an R in q such that x
is less than R is less than y?
I can't necessarily define
R by this formula here
and guaranteed that
R will be rational.
So for example, if
x equals root 2,
and let's say y equals 2
root 2, then x plus y over 2
equals 3/2 root 2, which
is not a rational number.
Because if it were a
rational number, then
I can multiply 2 through by
2/3 and say square root of 2
is a rational number.
So all of that to
say, that simply
by doing this trick of just
taking the average does not
necessarily mean that if
I take two real numbers,
1 less than the other, then
there exists a rational
in between them.
That's not so clear to see.
But this is one of the most--
this is one of the
basic facts about R,
is that the answer to
this question is, yes.
And that in some sense
the rational numbers
are dense in the real numbers.
For any to real numbers,
I can find a rational
in between them.
It's the first main property of
the real numbers we'll prove.
And it'll be a consequence of
a second property we'll prove,
which is called the
Archimedean property.
So this theorem has two parts.
Its first is called
Archimedean property of R.
And the statement of this
is, if x and y are in R,
and x is positive, then there
exists a natural number N,
such that nx is bigger than y.
And then the second
part of this theorem
is the statement that
the rationales are dense.
That the answer to
this question is, yes.
So this usually goes by
the name of the density
of the rationales.
So it states that if x and y
and in R, and x is less than y,
then there exists a
rational number little r,
such that x is less
than r is less than y.
So let's prove
the first theorem,
the first part of this theorem,
the Archimedean property.
So what do we have to use
to prove this theorem?
Just what we know about
the real numbers, the fact
that it's an ordered field with
the least upper bound property.
And you'll see how this least
upper bound property plays
a major role in all of
these elementary things we
prove about R.
So let's restate our hypothesis.
So suppose x and y are in r.
And x is less than--
and x is bigger than 0.
So we wish to show--
so just restating
this inequality here,
we wish to show--
the word show, you should read
as synonymous with prove--
that there exists
a natural number N,
such that n is
bigger than y over x.
That's just restating that.
So we're going to prove
this by contradiction.
So the proof will
go by contradiction.
So this is, again,
this is our hypothesis,
which we will assume
throughout the proof.
The thing we're trying to
prove is this statement here,
the second sentence.
So this is the thing
that we will negate.
We will not negate
the hypothesis,
we're negating what we
want to prove in the end.
And then arriving at
a false statement.
Therefore showing our
conclusion is true.
So we assume that the
second statement is false.
Again, we're assuming
the first statement.
So suppose not, i.e.
for all N a natural number, n is
less than or equal to y over x.
That's the negation of the
fact of there exists an integer
that's bigger than y over x.
So then that means then
the natural numbers
as a subset of the real
numbers is bounded above.
Now, the set of natural
numbers is a non-empty subset
of R, which is bounded above.
Therefore, it has a supremum.
So by the least upper
bound property of R,
N has a supremum,
call it a in R.
So since a is the supremum of N,
anything smaller than a cannot
be an upper bound for
the natural numbers.
Because remember, a is supposed
to be the least upper bound.
Anything smaller than that
cannot be an upper bound
for the natural numbers.
Is not an upper bound for N.
But what does that mean?
So if a minus 1 is not
an upper bound for N,
that means there must exist some
integer in N which is strictly
bigger than a minus 1.
There exists a
natural number, I'm
going to call it m, such that
a minus 1 is less than m.
But then, this implies
that a is less than m
plus 1, which
implies that a is not
an upper bound for
the natural numbers.
Because m plus 1-- m is an
integer, a natural number.
So m plus 1's a natural number.
And I've just found a
natural number bigger than a.
That means a can't be an upper
bound for the natural numbers.
But and therefore a does
not equal the sup of N.
And this is a contradiction.
Because A is defined
as a sup of N.
So from the assumption,
just to recap,
just from the assumption
that for all natural numbers
N, N is less than or
equal to y over x.
We concluded that it
has a supremum that's
not its supremum.
So that's a false statement.
And therefore, our
initial assumption
that for all
natural numbers N, N
is less than or equal to y
over x, that must be false.
And therefore, there
exist an N, which
is bigger than y over x, which
is what we wanted to prove.
So for the proof of the
second theorem, the density
of rational numbers, we'll do--
so we have three
cases to consider.
So both x and y
are real numbers.
x is less than y.
There are three
cases, call it A,
x is less than 0 is less than y.
B, 0 is bigger than or
equal to x is less than y.
And C, x is less than y is
less than or equal to 0.
So we want to find a rational
number between x and y.
So for this case,
this is pretty simple.
We just take R to be 0.
So I'm not going to say
anything about case A. I'm just
going to move on to case B.
So case B. So suppose x is
bigger than or equal to 0
and less than y.
Then by AP I'll refer to--
So that'll be shorthand notation
for the Archimedean property.
So part one, which we've
already proven is true.
By the Archimedean property,
there exists a natural number
N, such that N times y
minus x is bigger than 1.
Now, we're going to use
Archimedean property again.
There exists an integer
l and a natural number
l, such that l is
bigger than n times x.
Thus, the set of all integer--
of natural numbers
k, such that k
is bigger than nx is non-empty.
So this is a subset of
the natural numbers.
So it has a least element.
By the well ordering property
of the natural numbers,
S has a least element m.
Now what does this mean?
What does m have to satisfy?
What we're going to
show is that m over n
is in fact, a rational number
that is between x and y.
So the goal is, I guess--
so let me just make
a comment here.
So once we've made--
once we've found this
natural number, little n,
so that n times y minus
x is bigger than 1,
what does this mean?
This means n times y is
bigger than nx plus 1.
So our goal is then to find--
so this stuff in
brackets, you should not
consider as part of the proof.
This is me trying to explain
to you where from here
we would like to go to conclude
the proof that there exists
a rational number
between y and x.
So we have this inequality,
the Archimedean property
tells us there's a natural
number that satisfies this.
So what we would like to do is
find another natural number.
And I'm foreshadowing what's
to come-- a natural number m--
well, let's not--
I don't want you to give
you any false hopes.
I mean, they're not false.
It'll happen in a minute.
But let's call this j.
So that two things happen.
n times x is less than j.
And j is less than or
equal to nx plus 1.
So if we're able to find such
an integer j satisfying this,
these two inequalities,
then from this inequality
we would get that
ny is bigger than--
or this is bigger
than nx plus 1,
which is bigger than or equal
to j, which is bigger than nx.
I.e.
let me just rewrite
this. nx is less than j,
is less than n times y.
Or in other words, x is less
than j over m is less than y.
And here's our rational
number which we would choose.
So that's the game
plan, which maybe I
should have said
right after I came up
with this integer little n.
You may be asking why I come
up with this integer little n.
Well, we have to
start somewhere.
And the Archimedean
property gives us this.
And this somehow gives us
a scale to at least a scale
1 over n to kind of work on.
But anyway, so going
back to the proof.
So we have by the
well ordering property
of the natural
numbers, this set S,
which is a set of
all natural numbers
so that k is bigger than nx
has a least element little m.
Now m, so S has a least
element m, means m is in S.
So since m is in S,
this means simply
by the definition of what
S is, nx is less than m.
That's very good.
That's one of the
properties we wanted--
I wrote it as j, but we
wanted an integer to satisfy.
Since m is the least element
of S, m minus 1 is not in S.
So that implies that m minus
1 not in S means m minus 1
is less than or equal
to n times x, i.e.
n is less than or equal
to n times x plus 1.
Now, we'll combine these
two inequalities along
with the first one
involving n times y minus x.
So I'm just basically
rewriting what
I told you our goal was
here in this bracket.
Then, n times x is less than m.
And this is less than
or equal to n times
x plus 1, which by
our definition of n
in the first inequality we
have up there involving y
is less than n times y.
So we have nx is less
than m, is less than y.
So that means x is less than
m over n is this less than y.
So r equals m over n, which is
a proportion of natural numbers,
is our choice.
That's an awkward way
to finish a sentence.
But my mind went blank.
Anyways, so that
handles the case B,
that x is bigger
than or equal to 0.
So one small thing that I--
just a very minor comment.
If you've got all this, and
you understand it, that's fine.
But you may be asking since
I never actually said it
out loud, where did
I use the fact that x
is bigger than or equal to 0?
So where I used that-- so let's
just assume x is bigger than 0.
So what where did I use is
really right in this place
here.
So I don't want to spend
too much time on that.
But by being able to claim
that m minus 1 is not in S.
So what about case C?
So case C, we'll just
reduce to case B. Suppose
x is less than y, which is
less than or equal to 0.
Then 0 is bigger than or
equal to minus y, which
is bigger than minus x.
So by case B, there exists
a rational number, R tilde,
such that minus y is less than
R tilde is less than minus x.
Then this implies that
x is less than minus R
tilde is less than y.
So R equal to minus
R tilde does the job.
So that proves the theorem.
So we'll use this
in just a minute
to prove a simple statement
about sups and infs.
But before I use
it, let me go on.
And what I'd like to do
is state a different way
to verify that a number is a sup
of a set or the inf of a set.
So I'm just going to
state it for sups.
And there's an analogous
statement for infs.
So the theorem is this.
And this will actually
be on the assignment.
So assume S is a subset of R
is non-empty and bounded above.
So S has a supremum.
So I'm going to tell you
what the supremum satisfies.
And it's an if and
only if statement.
Then some number x equals
a sup of S if and only if--
so either I'll do
a double arrow,
or I'll write if and only if--
two conditions are satisfied.
The first is that x is
an upper bound for S.
And the second, so at one point,
or in the very near future,
we're going to be seeing
epsilons and deltas.
So I'll state it this way.
So you should start
seeing them now.
For every epsilon positive,
there exists an element y
in S such that x
minus epsilon is less
than y is less
than or equal to x.
So why is this--
why should this be the case?
Well, if S is all over
here to the left of x, then
and if I take something
smaller, so I'm
actually kind of giving you a
picture proof of one direction.
And so, if I take something
smaller, x minus epsilon,
then this cannot be
an upper bound for S.
So therefore, there
must exist some y in S
bigger than x minus epsilon.
And it's less than
or equal to x,
because x is an
upper bound for S.
So in fact, this picture is
a proof of this direction,
namely if x is
the supremum of S,
then these two
conditions are satisfied.
And then, on the
assignment I'll have
you prove the other
direction, basically,
that these two conditions
imply that a real number is
the supremum of S.
So let's use this
theorem and Archimedean
property to prove
a simple statement
about the sup of a simple set.
So I should-- so let
me also write here--
that I'm not going to
state it as a theorem.
But I'll just-- this is a remark
meaning I'm being a little bit
loose with what I'm writing
down, but it's true--
x equals inf of S.
So for S, a non-empty subset
which is bounded below,
there's an analogous
characterization
as x is a lower bound for s.
And for all epsilon positive,
there exists a y in S,
so that x is less than or
equal to y is less than x
plus epsilon.
So this is the analogous
statement for the inf,
for something to be the inf.
So this is, I guess you
could call it a theorem.
It's not a very
spectacular theorem.
But if I look at the set 1 minus
1 over N, in a natural number,
and I take its sup,
this is equal to 1.
So this shouldn't
surprise you too much.
Because what is this set?
This is the set 0, 1/2,
2/3, 3/4 4/5, and so on.
So you see 1 is
always bigger than
or equal to everything in here.
So it's certainly
an upper bound.
And everything is kind of
progressively getting closer
to 1.
So it should satisfy
the second property.
Namely, if I go a little
bit to the left of 1,
then I'll be able to
find something less than
or equal to 1 and bigger than
that thing to the left of 1.
And that'll be how we
prove this theorem.
So first off, since 1 minus
1 over n is less than 1,
for all natural
members N, this implies
1 is an upper
bound for this set.
Now we're going to
verify that one satisfies
that second property
of the theorem,
that for every epsilon positive,
I can find a natural number
little n, so that
1 minus 1 over n
is bigger than 1 minus epsilon.
And we'll use the Archimedean
property for that.
So if you're ever
supposed to show
something for every
epsilon positive,
then every proof should start
off with epsilon be positive.
In fact, I'll give you a
couple of points on the exam
if there's epsilon delta
m's whatever proofs, which
means you should prove
something for all epsilon--
I'll give you a couple
of points on the exam
if you just at least state
let epsilon be positive.
So let epsilon be positive.
So then, there exists--
so by the Archimedean property,
there exist a natural number N,
such that 1 over epsilon is
less than N. This is taking,
for example, in the statement
of the Archimedean property,
if you like, it's taking x to
be 1 and y to be 1 over epsilon.
Then 1 minus 1 over n--
so let's do it this way.
Then 1 minus epsilon is--
so since epsilon is less than--
1 over epsilon is
less than n, this
is equivalent to saying 1
over n is less than epsilon.
And therefore, minus epsilon
is less than minus 1 over n.
So then, 1 minus epsilon
is less than 1 minus 1
over n, which is as we have
up here, is less than 1.
Thus, there exists a
natural number N, so that--
so that went kind of quick.
So what I did was, I
found a natural number
N, which is bigger
than 1 over epsilon.
And from now on, typically,
I won't state it like this,
I'll state it more like this.
Which this follows from this.
So when I make a statement
like, choose a natural number
so that 1 over n is
less than epsilon,
that follows from the
Archimedean property
just by taking 1
over this inequality.
And so.
From there we concluded
that 1 minus epsilon
is less than 1 minus 1 over
n, which is still less than 1.
And therefore, we have
proven the second--
number two property of 1.
And thus by the theorem,
1 is equal to the supremum
of this set.
So let's get a little
more familiarity
with using sups and infs,
and in particular using
that theorem, which
I stated right
there, about this
characterization of the sup
as being an upper bound and
satisfying the second property
that for every
epsilon positive you
can find something
in the set which
is bigger than x minus epsilon.
So to do that, let's look at
a couple of different sets--
types of subsets
of real numbers.
So for x a real
number and a subset,
we define two sets, x plus a--
this is just a shift of a by x.
So this is a set of all elements
of the form x plus little a,
where little a is a
capital A. x times a,
this is a set of all elements
of the form x times a,
where a is in capital
A. So from now
on basically towards
the end, until almost
the end of the course,
we're working as in subsets
of the real numbers.
So these things are meaningful,
plus and multiplication.
So we have the
following theorem.
So let's-- let me
state the assumptions.
And then we'll probably
guess the conclusions.
If x is a real number,
and A is bounded above,
then the conclusion is x
plus a is bounded above.
And the supremum of
this set x plus A
is equal to x plus
the supremum of A.
We should be able to guess this.
Because let's assume A
is this interval here.
That would make the sup A--
this, let's say right
endpoint of this interval,
then when I shift everything
by x, then this point
sup A shifts to x
plus sup A, which
should be the supremum
of x plus capital A.
So this is not too surprising.
There are surprising
theorems in analysis.
We already saw of one, at least,
I thought it was surprising.
Hopefully you found
it surprising,
about the cardinality
of the power set
compared to the cardinality
of the original set.
You come up with this
strange-looking--
or the proof of that,
remember, you came up with this
strange-looking set
which you had to--
which in the end basically
referenced itself
in its definition, which led
to the conclusion we wanted.
But this one is not so scary.
This one you should
be able-- this theorem
you should be able to
believe and maybe even prove
without me telling you how to.
If not, that's fine too.
The other statement is
that if x is positive
and A is bounded above,
then x plus A, or x times A,
sorry, is bounded above.
And sup of x times A equals
x times the sup of A.
And again, so if I were to
draw a picture, and let's
say A is kind of symmetric
with respect to 0.
So there's sup of A,
and I multiply it by x.
Then this either fattens the
interval or makes it smaller.
So let's say I made it smaller.
Now to x times A,
then x times sup of A
would be the
supremum of this set.
Why x positive?
Well, the reason is because
if I multiply by x negative,
this not only shrinks
it but it flips things.
So in fact, there's a
statement in the book
about if x is
negative, then here you
would need to assume
A is bounded below.
So the corresponding
statement for x negative
is, if x is less than 0
and A is bounded below,
then x times A is bounded above.
Because multiplying by something
negative flips inequalities.
And the sup of x times
A is equal to minus
x times the inf of A.
Or there's no minus.
This should be sup
of x times A is
equal to x times the inf of A.
All right.
So let's prove
these two theorems
using this previous theorem
that I stated without proof,
but you'll prove in the
assignment about how
to characterize sups
of sets as upper bounds
and satisfying this
epsilon property.
So let me just restate
our assumptions.
So suppose x is in R,
and A is bounded above.
Then the number
sup A exists in R,
because R has the least
upper bound property.
A is a non-empty subset.
So I should have said
that, so all of this
is for a non-empty
subset of A, so that I'm
talking about something.
So I have a non-empty
subset, which
is bounded above by the
least upper bound property.
The supremum of A
exists in R. So now
I'm going to show that
x times the sup of A
satisfies that it's an
upper bound for x times A.
Then for all little
a in A, since sup
is an upper bound for
capital A, little a
is less than or equal to sup
A, which implies that for all a
in capital A, if I
multiply through by x,
I mean, if I add x to both
sides, x plus little a
is less than or equal
to x plus sup of A.
Which implies that
x plus sup of A
is an upper bound
for the set x plus A.
So that's the first
property we wanted
to prove of x plus
sup A. Now, we'll
prove the second property,
this epsilon property.
Let epsilon be positive.
Then by the previous theorem,
there exist a y in A such
that sup minus A is less
than epsilon is less than y
is less than or equal to sup A.
This is just from the fact
that the supremum of A
satisfies those two
conditions up there.
Now I just add x through all
of these inequalities, which
implies there exists a
y in A, such that x plus
sup A minus epsilon
is less than x
plus y, which is less than
or equal to x plus sup of A.
And that proves the
second property.
Because what have I done?
I found that for every epsilon
positive, an element of the set
x plus A--
so I'll even--
I'll restate this--
which implies there exists
an element z in the set
x plus capital A,
namely x plus y.
So that x plus sup A minus
epsilon is less than z
is less than or equal
to x plus sup A.
And that's the
second property which
we wanted to prove,
this epsilon property.
Now we've proven it for x plus
sup A, for the set x plus A.
Thus, sup of x plus A
equals x plus sup A.
So we proved that x plus sup
A is the supremum of x plus A
by showing it was an upper bound
and it satisfied this epsilon
property.
I mean, it's essentially
the same proof
for x times capital A.
You just replace pluses
with multiplication.
How much time do we have?
So in fact, I'm running
a little short on time.
I guess a little
slow-moving today.
So I will not go
through actually
write the proof of
the second part,
simply because the
same logic works.
Only now, I replace
everything by multiplication
by x instead of addition by x.
Well, almost.
OK, why not.
Let's go through the
proof real quick.
I just won't spend as much
time explaining stuff.
So now we want to do--
we want to show x times sup
A is a supremum of x times A.
So suppose x is positive
and A is bounded above.
Then sup A, again, exists in
R, because A is bounded above.
And because sup A is an
upper bound for capital A,
then for all a in
capital A, a is less than
or equal to sup A, which implies
that for all a in capital A,
x times little a is
less than or equal to x
times sup A. Which implies that
x times sup A is an upper bound
for x times A.
So we've proven that x times sup
A is an upper bound for the set
x times A. We now want to verify
this epsilon property for x
times sup A with respect
to the set x times A.
So let epsilon be positive.
And I'm going to put
it in brackets, again,
what we want to do,
what we want to define.
We want to show there
exists z in x times A,
so that x times sup A minus
epsilon is less than z.
z is always less than or
equal to x times sup A,
since we've proven x time sup A
is an upper bound for this set.
So I'm not going to keep
writing the second inequality.
So this is what
we want to prove.
We haven't proven it yet.
So let epsilon be positive.
Then just as we did
in the plus case,
then there exists an element
y in A such that sup A minus--
now here, we're going to choose
y not exactly for epsilon here.
Remember, the statement
for number two
holds for sup A
for every epsilon.
In particular, I can
choose anything I want here
and find a y in between sup
A minus whatever I want here,
which is positive in sup A.
So instead of
putting epsilon here
like I did before, I'm
going to put epsilon over x.
Which I can do,
because x is positive,
which means epsilon over
x is some positive number.
Now, why did I choose
epsilon over x?
Because magic happens.
Then that means there
exists a y in A,
such that if I multiply
through by x I get x times sup.
A minus epsilon is less than
x times y, is less than--
so I'm going to stop
writing this inequality.
Because this is always true,
because x times sup A is bigger
than or equal to x times y.
Which implies there exists
a z in x times A. Namely,
z equals x times y,
where y is from here,
such that x times sup A
minus epsilon is less than z.
And therefore, x times sup A
satisfies the second epsilon
property with respect
to S given by x times A.
And that's the end.
So you see that I
wanted this in the end.
So I chose y to give me this
slightly different thing
for epsilon over x.
Because in the end, I would
multiply through by x.
And I wanted this.
When we do proofs
for limits, you'll
see we're always trying to make
something less than epsilon.
So quite often, we'll
have to choose something
to be less than epsilon
over 5, or epsilon
over some number for everything
to work out in the end,
just like we did here.
So that's kind of a
preview of things to come.
And one last simple theorem
about sups and infs.
This really doesn't use that
theorem, but just basically
what the definition
of sups and infs are.
Namely that if A and
B are subsets of R,
and for all, let's say, with A
bounded above, B bounded below,
and for all x, y, for all
x in A, and for all y in B,
x is less than or equal to y.
Then sup of A is less than
or equal to the inf of B.
So picture-wise, here's
A. Everything here
sits below everything in B.
So B has to be over here.
And therefore, the sup
of A, which is there,
has to be less than or equal to
the INF of B, which is there.
That's the picture that
goes along with this.
But how do we
actually prove this?
I mean, we have to
use the definitions.
Pictures do not suffice.
Although they inform
us, they don't suffice.
So this is quite simple.
So I'm not going to
rewrite the hypotheses now,
because it'd take a little bit.
But so if for all x in--
let me-- basically
what we're going to do
is, we're going to take
a sup and then an inf.
So let y be in B.
Then for all x in A,
x is less than or
equal to y, which
implies y is an
upper bound for A.
And therefore, the
supremum of A, which
is the least upper bound, has to
be smaller than or equal to y.
Thus, we've proven for all
y in B, sup A is less than
or equal to y.
Which implies that sup A
is a lower bound for B.
And by that same
logic a minute ago,
so remember the infemum of B
is the greatest lower bound.
So if I take any
lower bound of B,
it has to be less than or
equal to the inf of B. So
which implies sup A is less
than or equal to inf B.
So we're starting to close
out here our discussion of--
or at least our discussion
of the elementary properties
of the real numbers.
So let me say just
a couple of things
about the absolute value.
And let me recall
how this is defined.
At least, this is how it
should have been defined
from your calculus class.
If x is in R, we define
the absolute value of x.
This is either x if x is
bigger than or equal to 0,
or minus x if x is less
than or equal to 0.
Note that these two
things agree when x is 0.
So that I'm not defining
the absolute value
of x to be two different
things when x equals 0.
So and what is this
really meant to be?
It's supposed to be--
it's supposed to measure
the distance from--
or it's supposed to represent--
I shouldn't say,
is the distance,
because I haven't told
you what a distance means.
But what is it
supposed to represent?
It's supposed to represent the
distance from x to 0, which is
why it's always non-negative.
I mean, if I have
x was over here.
And this distance is
meant to be absolute value
of x [INAUDIBLE] that y.
So in fact, that's the first
thing that [INAUDIBLE]..
I'm just going to prove
some very simple properties
of the absolute value.
I mean, again, these
properties should not
be surprising to you.
You should know all of them.
But we're trying
to get familiar--
that's a tough word to say--
familiarities, or
familiarity with proofs.
So I'm going to do is many
proofs as I can for you.
So the first statement
is, for all x in R,
absolute value of x
is bigger than 0--
bigger than or equal to 0.
And the absolute value equals
0 if and only if x equals 0.
The second property is
that for all x in R,
the absolute value of x equals
the absolute value of minus x.
For all xy in R, if I take the
absolute value of the product,
this is equal to the product
of the absolute values.
For all x in R, the
absolute value of x squared
equals the absolute
value of x squared.
The fifth property is,
if x and y is in R,
then x is less than or
equal to y if and only
if minus y is less than
or equal to x is less than
or equal to y.
And the sixth property
that we'll prove
is that for all x
in R, x is less than
or equal to its absolute value.
So again, these are
not too surprising.
But we'll go through the
proofs, because that's
the point of this class.
Later on in life you'll come
across some more interesting
theorems than
definitely this one.
So if-- so we're going to prove
this first statement, that if x
is in R, the absolute value of
x is bigger than or equal to 0.
So if x is bigger
than or equal to 0,
then the absolute value
of x is by definition
equal to x, which is
bigger than or equal to 0.
If x is less than or equal
to 0, then the absolute--
then minus x is bigger
than or equal to 0.
And by the definition
of the absolute value,
the absolute value of x
is equal to minus x, which
is bigger than or equal to 0.
So that's proven that
the absolute value of x
is always bigger
than or equal to 0.
So now, let's prove
this statement.
Absolute value of x equals
0 if and only if x equals 0.
So when you see an if and
only if, or two arrows here,
that means there's two
statements you need to prove,
that this implies this,
and this implies this.
So let's start with
this direction.
Usually in if and only if,
there is an easy direction.
If x equals 0, then
this is clear simply
from the definition.
Then absolute value of
x equals x equals 0.
Let's go with the
other direction.
So suppose the absolute
value of x equals 0.
And if x is bigger
than or equal to 0,
we get that x is equal to
its absolute value of x
is equal to 0.
If x is less than or
equal to 0, then minus x
is equal to its absolute
value of x, which equals to 0,
or x equals 0.
So assuming the absolute
value of x is 0,
we've proven that x
equals 0 in both cases.
So that proves the
first property.
So now, we're on to
proving number two.
So number two, for all x in
R, the absolute value of x
equals minus x.
So we'll do that by, again,
we have to consider two cases.
x is non-negative or
x is non-positive.
So if x is bigger
than or equal to 0,
then minus x is less
which implies that the
absolute value of minus x
equals minus minus x, which
equals x, which equals
the absolute value of x
since we're in the case
that x is non-negative.
If x is less than or
equal to 0, n minus x
is bigger than or
equal to 0, which
implies that the
absolute value of minus x
is equal to minus x, which
is, since x is less than
or equal to 0, and
by the definition
of the absolute value, equal
to absolute value of x.
So that proves too.
So for all xy real number, the
absolute value of x times y
is equal to the absolute value
of x times absolute value of y.
So we need to
consider two cases.
One of them is--
both of them are non-negative,
both of them are non-positive.
And both of them are--
or one of them is positive,
one of them is non-negative,
or one of them is non-negative,
one of them is non-positive.
So if x is bigger
than or equal to 0,
and y is bigger than or
equal to 0, then x times y
is bigger than or
equal to 0, which
implies x, the absolute
value of x times y
is equal to x times y.
And since x is
non-negative, that's
equal to its absolute value.
Since y is non-negative, that's
If x is bigger
than or equal to 0,
and y is less than
or equal to 0,
then minus x times y is
bigger than or equal to 0,
which implies that the
absolute value of x times y
is equal to--
so I should say, let's
write it this way.
This is equal to minus xy, which
is equal to x times minus y.
And since y is negative, minus y
is equal to its absolute value.
And since x is non-negative, x
So this is equal to that.
Another piece of chalk.
Now the case that--
so you might be
thinking about what
about x negative and y
non-negative, so y bigger
than or equal to 0, x
less than or equal to 0.
It's the same proof,
just exchange x and y.
So I'm not going
to do that case.
And if x is less
than or equal to 0,
y is less than or equal to 0.
Then this implies that minus x
is bigger than or equal to 0.
And minus y is bigger
than or equal to 0.
Which by this first
case, which we've proven,
now applied to
minus x and minus y,
I get that the absolute value
of minus x times minus y,
which is equal to x times y, so
minus x times minus y is equal
to x times y.
This is equal to the absolute
value of minus x times
the absolute value of minus y.
And by number two, which
we've already proven,
which is that the absolute
value of minus the number
is equal to the absolute
value of the number again,
we get that.
So that's three.
And for four, this is just
a special case of three.
Take y equals x in three.
Now, for number five,
it's an if and only if.
So we need to prove
two directions.
Namely, we'll assume
this, and then prove this,
and then assume this,
and then prove that.
So suppose-- so this is this
direction, meaning suppose--
our assumption is going to be,
suppose the absolute value of x
is less than or equal to y.
So then, x is bigger
than or equal to 0.
Then this means that--
so if the absolute value of
x is less than or equal to y,
that automatically tells
you y is non-negative.
So therefore, minus
y is less than
or equal to 0,
which is less than
or equal to x, which equals
the absolute value of x, which
is less than or equal to y.
I.e.
minus y is less than or equal
to x is less than or equal to y.
So in the other case, that x
is less than or equal to 0,
I can apply basically this
part which I've already proven.
n minus x is bigger
than or equal to 0.
And the absolute
value of minus x,
which is equal to the
absolute value of x,
is less than or
equal to y, which
implies by this first case I've
proven applied now to minus x
here, that minus y is less
than or equal to minus
x is less than or equal to y.
And multiplying through by minus
1 flips all the inequalities
and also flips the
sign, which basically
means it leaves this
inequality unchanged
if I replace this by x.
So multiply through by minus
1 flips the inequalities
and proves what we want to do.
So in either case--
so for the first case, we
actually wrote down a proof,
and we reduced the second case,
x negative, to the first case
that we've already proven.
So we've proven that this
inequality, the absolute value
of x less than or equal
to y, implies that this.
So now, we need to prove
the converse direction.
So the converse direction.
So suppose minus y is less
than or equal to x is less than
or equal to y.
And I want to prove the
absolute value of x is less than
or equal to y.
So if x is bigger
than or equal to 0,
then the absolute value
of x is equal to x,
which by this inequality
is less than or equal to y.
If x is less than or
equal to 0, then minus y
is less than or equal to
x, implies that minus x
is less than or equal to y.
And because x is
negative, minus x
is equal to its absolute value.
And therefore, we've proven
the absolute value of x
is less than or equal to y.
So we've proven number five.
And number six, so for
number six, what do we do?
We just take y equals the
absolute value of x from five,
to conclude that x is less than
or equal to the absolute value
of x and bigger than or equal to
minus the absolute value of x.
And that's the proof.
Now, I'm going to
prove one last theorem.
So this one is actually
very important,
about the absolute value.
It's probably--
so this inequality
is one of the most important
tools in all of analysis.
And you get to see it right here
in your first analysis class.
There's two-- basically
two other things
we'll prove at some-- at one
point, which I don't know,
are the two other most
important things in analysis.
This is the triangle inequality.
And the other two are
integration by parts and change
of variables.
Those three things fuel
the analysis machine.
So this theorem, so this
is the triangle inequality.
And it states for all xy in R,
the absolute value of x plus y
is less than or equal to
the absolute value of x
plus the absolute value of y.
Why is it called the
triangle inequality?
Well, let's try to think, so
although x and y are elements
of the real number
line, let's instead
try and think of these
as two vectors instead.
So here's the vector x.
And then, let's say--
so actually, I'm
running out of time.
So I think we'll stop here.